foreign
and I am shaking with anxiety
my stomach is full of butterflies
I am about to ask my mom a difficult
question
and I am not sure I am prepared to hear
the answer
mom
is daddy my real dad
we are sitting under a deeply shaded
patio on a hot summer day
my mom looks up from her book with an
expression that shows no surprise
she knew I'd eventually notice that my
dad's Acorn Brown Skin does not match my
fair skin
that his jet black braid clashes with my
then Blonde one
yes she says daddy is your real dad and
in fact
other than me just knowing that
we've had to validate your paternity
with the federal government because you
and Daddy are Native American
as she proceeds patiently with an
explanation my mom uses two words that
have come to Define my identity more
than the color of my skin
blood quantum
blood Quantum is a standard of
measurement used to determine the amount
of Native American Heritage a person
possesses
along with the blood of purebred dogs
and thoroughbred horses
the blood of Native Americans is
measured and verified by the federal
government
blood Quantum is unfamiliar to most
non-native people but within Indian
country
and for native people across our
continent
blood Quantum carries immeasurable
importance
it is deeply intertwined with identity
and recognition
and a certain amount is required for
enrollment at most tribes including my
own
My Tribe the Rincon band of Lucena
Indians is one of the
574 federally recognized tribes in the
United States today
the tribes are sovereign Nations
with distinctive rights including the
sacred right to select their own
citizens
and yet despite the sovereignty of the
tribes
their use of blood quantum
demonstrates the influence of the
federal government
when I was born my parents followed a
well-worn trail blazed by millions of
native people who have pursued
enrollment in a tribe
not dissimilar to a foreigner seeking
citizenship in a new country
my tribal enrollment process involved
paperwork legal attestations and proof
of lineage
ultimately
I was issued a certificate of degree of
Indian blood
by the U.S department of Interiors
Bureau of Indian Affairs
with this verification I was enrolled in
the tribe of my father
my grandfather my great-grandfather
and back through the generations
the U.S federal government began
imposing blood Quantum on Native people
as early as the 1700s
assigning a quantifiable value to a
person's indian-ness meant dilution
could occur naturally through
inter-tribal and inter-racial unions
for the federal government blood Quantum
was an efficient means to an inevitable
end
Extinction
even today many tribes including my own
Embrace blood quantum
because they are grasping for a
scientific method
to quantify ancestry
but blood Quantum is a knife that cuts
both ways
as blood Thins
native people are excluded
recently
I heard a heartbreaking situation that
occurred in Southern California
an enrolled tribal member
father of twin boys suffered an untimely
death
his college age Sons grew up on the
reservation but do not possess enough
blood Quantum to be enrolled members of
their father's tribe leaving them
ineligible to inherit their childhood
home
because of blood Quantum they had no
standing to remain on the reservation
once their father was gone
consequences of blood Quantum are real
and Powerful
there can be a loss of benefits like a
residence
but just as devastating are the negative
effects on a person's identity and sense
of belonging
throughout my life
I've met people who when they learn I'm
Native American have said something like
oh I have native Heritage too but I have
no idea what tribe
imagine knowing your tribe growing up on
your reservation practicing your customs
but being told you do not have enough
blood
to be recognized as a treasured citizen
of your nation
can you imagine how that would make
you feel
each tribe has the right to determine a
path forward
I speak for no one but myself as I stand
here before you
but
without an alternative to blood Quantum
we are facing the extinction of many
tribes
the Protectors of our Irreplaceable
indigenous culture
blood quantum
designed for extermination
cannot be allowed to threaten the
extraordinary Heritage of my children
my grandchildren
my great-grandchildren and down through
the generations
I believe there is a solution more
powerful than blood quantum
what if
we embrace the ways our ancestors Define
citizenship
through proximity and time invested in
family
traditions and ways of life
our relatives built Nations strong and
true
these nations were rooted in something
intangible
unquantifiable and yet Unbreakable
kinship
redefining tribal citizenship around
kinship Embraces the spiritual emotional
and cultural links between us which are
stronger than anything simply biological
kinship would allow the tribes to select
those people who bear the strongest
family affiliations and cultural
connections
creating cohesion
that is far more powerful than a
precarious measurement of blood
in Lucena
we say no shamlovic or my heart is good
an expression of gratitude an
open-heartedness
for my fellow natives who are hearing my
words
I offer them with love and support of
our precious Sovereign Nations
and for my non-native audience
future founders of businesses writers of
policy and leaders of change
I invite you to care about the native
people of our continent
and to contemplate how your choices can
strengthen not dilute the connections
between us
notion lovik
let us Embrace kinship
thank you
[Music]